bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 sur tv
fil 78 une heure pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale dans le département
principalement du côté de saint quentin
en yvelines en direct dès 18 heures
voici tout de suite les titres de ce 26
février quelques-uns des sujets que nous
allons aborder ce soir nous parlerons de
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin tout
d'abord depuis ce mardi matin à montigny
le bretonneux se déroulent les
rencontres de l'association créactive
une association qui veut rompre
l'isolément de celle qui devient chef
d'entreprise sa présidente est en
plateau ainsi que l'une des
intervenantes avec nous parlerons des
techniques de management également sur
ce plateau la maire-adjointe de magny
les hameaux en charge de la vie
associative puisque sa commune consacre
une semaine aux femmes
le thème de la manifestation qui se
déroule jusqu'au 10 mars sur les routes
d'europe
le football américain ce ne sont pas
seulement des joueurs ceux des templiers
d'elancourt ce sont également des
cheerleaders est là sur des
chorégraphies avant et pendant à les
temps de pause des matches à malgré le
froid elles ont assuré le spectacle ce
week end pour accompagner la victoire de
leur équipe est toujours en secours du
hand fauteuil a plaisir à l'occasion de
la coupe de la ligue c'est du hand
féminin en ile-de-france seulement deux
clubs proposent cette initiation dont
celui de montigny le bretonneux et ce
plateau est très féminin ce soir valérie
bonsoir valérie aux rivaux avec vous
nous verrons tout à l'heure au début de
la seconde partie de cette édition du 7
la question de l'environnement la
chronique de l'environnement comme
chaque mardi
oui absolument nous accueillerons la
présidente de l'association les
rencontres de pornic qui met en place
des actions de sensibilisation à
l'écologie à l'environnement et à
l'économie sociale et solidaire
ce sera aux alentours de 18h30 si vous
me suivez en direct l'actualité du jour
c'est le conseil économique social et
environnemental cese qui a jugé
aujourd'hui est recevable sur le fond la
pétition des opposants au texte de loi
légalisant le mariage et l'adoption pour
les couples homosexuels ont un
communiqué a publié cet après-midi
justifier ce choix
un texte à l'étude par le parlement ne
peut faire l'objet d'une remise en
question sous cette forme
rappelons que les députés ont validé
cette réforme elle les sénateurs doivent
se prononcer partir du 2 avril les
opposants qui avait réuni quelques 700
mille signatures il souhaitait avant
tout l'ouverture d'un débat leur chef de
file philippe brillault le maire ump du
chesnay évoque une décision politique
écouté il fallait résumer le résultat
qui vient d'être donné par le bureau
j'aurais tendance à dire le président de
le voir aux ordres de matignon le
constatons aujourd'hui que la réponse du
président du cse qui préside comme elle
le bureau et une décision avant tout
politique appartement mais une décision
politique
nous aurons une réaction on nous dit on
ne peut pas faire une pétition
lorsqu'il ya un texte de loi à
l'assemblée
conformément à l'article 69 de la
constitution
faux pourquoi parce que si cette édition
qui est le troisième alinéa de la
constitution de l'article 69 n'était pas
possible pendant un projet de loi ou
autre et bien l'article 5 de la loi
organique lorette précisé à partir du
moment où cette décision est prise et
que nous notre objectif c'était
d'apaiser la situation
et bien cette décision ne va pas le pv
et qu'au contraire elle va mobiliser
tous les pétitionnaires alors qu'il
fallait calmer le jeu point votre
réaction dans le département celle de
l'abbé grosjean le curé de saint cyr
l'école il s'est beaucoup exprimée ces
derniers mois lui aussi fait partie des
opposants à ce mariage pour tous via
twitter il a fait part cet après midi de
sa satisfaction tout de même puisque ce
conseil économique le cea décidé de
s'autosaisir afin de tout de même mené
des débats
seulement aucune date aucun calendrier
n'a été communiqué le collectif des
opposants qui appellent à une nouvelle
manifestation nationale le 24 mars à
paris pour je cite poursuivre la lutte
contre le projet de loi du gouvernement